[Música]
en colombia se cumple una semana de las
masivas manifestaciones en su mayoría en
paz contra el gobierno en las denuncias
por la represión policial sin embargo
hay focos de actos vandálicos los
fallecidos llegan a 24 pero ong locales
se elevan las víctimas a 37 hoy siguen
los diálogos del gobierno pero sin los
líderes del paro
la unión europea se mostró abierta a
dialogar para determinar si se retira la
protección de propiedad intelectual a
las vacunas contra el hobbit 19 luego de
que eeuu presentará la propuesta el
anuncio de washington generó la
reprobación de empresas y farmacéuticas
elecciones en reino unido- este jueves
de escocia y gales celebran comicios
autonómicos e inglaterra municipales 48
millones de ciudadanos están llamados a
votar pero sin duda la posibilidad de un
nuevo referendo sobre la permanencia de
escocia en el reino unido- determina el
pulso de la contienda
buenos días para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france 24
soy valentina torres sánchez iniciamos
en colombia que vivió su octavo día
consecutivo de multitudinarias
movilizaciones en su mayoría pacíficas
contra el gobierno de ban duque y ante
las denuncias de represión policial sin
embargo siguen los saqueos y otros actos
vandálicos en varias ciudades del país
las cifras oficiales hablan de 24
muertos pero las ong las elevan a 37 y
añaden que hay denuncias de más de 1.700
casos de violencia por parte de la
fuerza pública este miércoles iniciaron
los diálogos propuestos por el jefe de
estado ivan duque pero sin la presencia
de los líderes del paro que se espera se
reúnan con él el lunes hoy la cita es
con la rama judicial se prevé que este
jueves los líderes del paro determinen
si las manifestaciones continuarán hasta
ese día
seguimos en colombia la movilización
indígena sigue acompañando las
manifestaciones en cali en el sur
occidente del país a lo largo de la
semana han ido llegando distintos
colectivos y poblaciones indígenas y
actualmente hay alrededor de 5000
personas consideran que cali ha sido el
epicentro de las protestas y se han
querido sumar para aportar sus
estrategias nuestros enviados especiales
luís muñoz y juan carlos zapatas
tuvieron con un guardia indígena en uno
de los puntos de concentración
esto es puerto resistencia una de las
comunidades autónomas de cali nacidas
del paro nacional allí está el campo del
pueblo nasa y guardia indígena participa
en la mina de 5000 personas una forma de
llevar la instalación interna de los
territorios al exterior no venimos así
como nos han dicho que la guardia
indígena venía a violentar al pueblo
cullen y desmentir nosotros venimos a
acompañar a hacer la fuerza al ser la
fuerza del pueblo
los guardias indígenas son la principal
defensa que tienen las comunidades al
territorio del campo sólo lleva un
machete y un bastón con eso y la palabra
se enfrenta a paramilitares guerrilleros
narcotraficantes y ejército un cargo de
riesgo que heredó de su padre y que ya
ha transmitido a uno de sus hijos la
lucha que quiero construir para ellos
es un dolor que siento pero la misma
rabia me hace fuerte porque desarrolla
nos debe permitir que nuestros hijos
tengan la tranquilidad está bien también
es un compromiso y un motivo de orgullo
los guardias indígenas son respetados en
la comunidad a mí me tocó la primera vez
con mi papá salir que si a mi hijo
cuides hay que que hay que dar se lo
digo como usted tienen que estar aquí
atento a lo que va a pasar bien en la
primera arremetida que yo viví en una
movilización decía a liszt aquí comienza
a escribir mi historia de resistencia tu
ver campo no tiene miedo a la muerte
para los indígenas en un mensaje y el
legado continúa más allá de su vida una
convicción de paz y comunidad que están
instaurando en las protestas en cádiz
aquí no hay terrorismo
aquí hay escuelas
previamente conversamos con león
valència agudelo director y fundador de
la fundación paz y reconciliación de
colombia que nos explicó cómo se
interpreta que el gobierno inicie los
diálogos sin los líderes de las
manifestaciones pese al llamado de
numerosos sectores y también nos contó
algunas de las peticiones de los
manifestantes
pues el gobierno está repitiendo una
fórmula del primer paro de noviembre de
2019 que llamara a una conversación
nacional de esa primera experiencia no
llevó a ningún lugar no hay una decisión
y una voluntad de hacer cambios los
cambios que siguen la protesta social o
que exigen los partidos de oposición se
convierte el llamado el gobierno siempre
en un engaño ojalá esta oportunidad no
sea así porque las protestas pueden
seguir y pueden derivar en lo que
ocurrió en chile que fue una oleada de
largos meses de protesta hasta obligar
al gobierno a ofrecer un cambio
constitucional que fue la corrección en
chile aquí lo que se busca es un pacto
social y político alredor de unas
reivindicaciones muy sentidas de la
gente una primera es
y hay que hacer una reforma policial hay
que sacar el esmad ahí que hay que
abolir el esmad y hay que hacer una
reforma policial pasar
la policía al ministerio del interior
sacarla el ministerio de defensa y
convertirla en un cuerpo realmente
ciudadano que me atropella a la gente
una segunda reivindicación es una renta
básica para los sectores populares en
medio esta pandemia no y de la grave
crisis social una tercera y retira una
reforma a la salud que privatiza más y
fortalecer la salud pública y una cuarta
es cumplir los acuerdos de paz es que
aquí se hicieron un acuerdo de paz y no
se ha cumplido eso genera una angustia
muy grande en muchos sectores campesinos
campo para
para atender a la población esas son
algunas de las reivindicaciones de dónde
se saca la plata hay muchas fórmulas de
los economistas en colombia o fórmulas
serias para sacar la plata en vez de
hacer lo que iban a hacer una reforma
tributaria contra la clase media contra
los sectores populares para gravar más a
la gente y eso fue lo que despertó la
indignación ahora estamos en cómo
recuperamos la estabilidad esto no va a
ser fácil hay unos niveles de violencia
muy altos está el gobierno colombiano ha
acogido el presidente de duke
paradójicamente el camino de venezuela
en el camino de maduro que es
militarizar el país reprimir la protesta
pensando que así la va a controlar pues
no va a ser así este país es distinto
venezuela y aquí la soledad de protesta
seguramente van a seguir y la violencia
se va a tornar más aguda porque los con
la gente que está armada en colombia es
mucha la gente que ha aprendido
prácticas de violencia es mucha y
entonces la policía no va a poder
controlar sólo con la fuerza a todos
estos manifestantes primero y a un poco
de gente que aprovecha las
manifestaciones para hacer violencia y
para hacer destrucción
en otras noticias la presidenta de la
comisión europea ursula von der leyen
afirmó que europa está preparada para
debatir una posible exención de las
patentes de las vacunas contra el cob y
19 horas después del presidente de
francia de manuel makoun se mostró a
favor de la propuesta pero insistió en
que esto no ayudaría a los países más
pobres por lo que la prioridad sigue
siendo ceder las dosis
las reacciones se producen tras el
anuncio del presidente joe biden sobre
su intención de levantar los derechos
intelectuales de esas vacunas de georg
kim hyunjoon es su red y la unión
europea también está dispuesta a debatir
cualquier propuesta que aborde la crisis
de forma eficaz y pragmática y por eso
estamos dispuestos a discutir cómo la
propuesta estadounidense de exención de
la protección de la propiedad
intelectual para las vacunas podría
ayudar a lograr ese objetivo
faber vaccines for health ciudad
objective este jueves hay elecciones
locales en el reino unido- eligen al
parlamento local en gales y escocia pero
la atención se centra en este último la
primera ministra escocesa nicola store
describe esta votación como la más
importante en la historia de su país uno
de los cuatro que conforman el reino
unido- su colectividad el nacionalista
partido nacional escocés lidera la
intención de voto y cuenta con el
respaldo de los verdes la votación
promete ser decisiva en el proyecto
independentista escocés logra si logra
la mayoría suficiente exterior buscará
impulsar un referendo que abra el camino
hacia la separación del reino unido
no quería salir de europa soy
fundamentalmente europea y nos dijeron
la última vez que votamos a nuestra
gente se le dijo que si votaban para
quedarse no saldrían de europa y lo
hicimos y eso está mal
el verdadero preferiría que escocia se
quedara en reino unido así que
preferiría un partido que lo apoye así
que ya sabes por quién no votaría no
olvido arico
para finalizar damos un vistazo a lo que
titula nuestra web france24 puntocom a
esta hora estas son algunas de las
razones por las que continúan las
protestas en colombia
llegamos hacia el final de esta misión
pero volvemos en breve con más noticias
quédense aquí en france 24
[Música]